بين خيارات احلاها مر تجد ملايين الاسر
السودانيه نفسها في ظل استمرار المواجهات
المسلحه لليوم الثالث عشر فاما المخاطره
بالبقاء في منازلها رغم ما قد يجر ذلك من
امكانيه التعرض للقذائف والرصاص القادم من
طرفي الصراع فضلا عن تزايد صعوبه تامين
الاحتياجات الاساسيه من الغذاء والماء
والدواء او المخاطره برحله نزوح نحو مناطق
اخرى امنه داخل البلاد او اتخاذ قرار
اللجوء الى دول الجوار
وفيما يتعلق بمسارات النزوح فان العاصمه
الخرطوم لا تزال تشهد موجات نزوح يوميه
باتجاه الشرق والشمال وصولا الى مدينه
بورتسودان والحدود مع مصر كما شهدت مدينه
نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور نزوحا
داخليا لنحو 30 الف شخص وفق منظمه الهجره
الدوليه اما ولايه شمال كردفان نزوح
ثمانيه الاف شخص مع اندلاع المواجهات
ولايه شمال دارفور شهدت بدورها نزوحا
داخليا باتجاه مناطق امنه قدرتها منظمه
الهجره الدوليه باكثر من 16 الف شخص وعلى
ما يبدو فان التكثيف عمليات اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب في السودان قد حفز تسارع حركه
لجوء السودانيين الى دول الجوار وسط
مناشده من المفوضيه الساميه لشؤون
اللاجئين لتلك الدول ابقاء حدودها مفتوحه
للاشخاص الباحثين عن الاماني والحمايه
مسارات حركه اللجوء بدت على النحو التالي
من ولايتي كسلاوي الجضارف في الجنوب
الشرقي للسودان باتجاه كل من ارتريا
واثيوبيا من ولايتين للابيض وشرق دارفور
جنوبي البلاد الى دوله جنوب السودان التي
يقدر بان نحو عشره الاف سوداني قد لجاوا
اليها حتى الان من ولايه جنوب دارفور
باتجاه جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى من ولايتي
شمال وغرب دارفور باتجاه الجاره تشاد التي
يقدر بان نحو 30 الف سوداني قد لجاوا
اليها حتى الان رغم ان مفوضيه اللاجئين
تقدر بان الارقام قد ترتفع بشكل كبير جدا
فالتوقعات بان يفر نحو 270 الف سوداني الى
دوله جنوب السودان وتشاد وحدهما في حال
استمرار المعارك